hey moviegoers
my name is ryan wright and i'm jerry hi
my name is arzuboo
welcome to reese instac
where we give you reasons to see and a
chance not to see whatever movie we're
reviewing based off of its movie trailer
so tonight on the show we have uh a
persian girl with us
our zoo hello yeah so specific yeah no
absolutely you know and uh hey persian
community right like you just had to
mention that i'm persian we're reaching
out to the persian demographic not just
the persian demographics but also you
know more black people we know black
people like black guys like persian
girls this is a fun stereotype and i'm
hoping black people will appreciate what
we're trying to do well ryan you're
always right aren't you yes ryan is
always right
i don't think you have to be black to to
like persian people i mean yeah i mean i
like persian you are maybe you can be i
think persian girls are hot regardless
like uh yeah not all persian girls well
sam they were all racist not all person
is attractive i think i just had like
not every person is hot yeah that's a
fact but she you know she's hot though
comment below and let us know if you
think she's hot thank you ryan and if
you think she's ugly i'm gonna
do something to you yeah uh why we want
to argue on the show is because she
hates movies she does not like movies
and she really doesn't this isn't a
gimmick she also hates fun yeah
she hates you know what it's just the
concept of sitting in a movie theater
for two hours in the dark and not being
able to just be on your phone oh and be
on your phone and it's just like they
have big squishy chairs but listen i'd
rather be like watching a movie on my
couch on netflix or something
okay well so you don't hate movies you
just hate going to the theater and the
sound is like 540 000 amps up your ear
that almost sounds scientific while you
are pointing out facts about movie
theater experience that is exactly why
people love the movie theater experience
because it pulls you into the world arzu
boo you know what i think people just
like seeing movies because it's just
something to do on a friday night with
your significant other
oh wow i disagree
jerry and i are going to disagree with
you because i s i've seen many movies
without a significant other this was
going to be a trailer-thon show but i
think we're just going to have a fight
now movies are such jokes when you're
like in high school and you're like oh
my god him and i saw a movie but it's so
implied you didn't really watch the
movie but but a movie is also well maybe
you should go to a movie alone for a
while you should try seeing just watch
the art happen
yeah
we're gonna show her some trailers with
us and you know we'll see at the end if
she wants to go watch the movie or not
and if she does want to go watch it
she'll watch it with us and uh she can
review it with us and let her know about
her anxiety driven experience just she
has some persian movies for you to watch
no no no
this review is also going to be
translated into farsi so if you oh it's
going to be a good damn review really
reaching out there and you can't tell by
the shirt but she has really big boobs
no i don't
know she does if you get lucky to find
her on facebook look up them boobies
don't do that
yeah oh well i suggest you do it all
right guys so the first movie we're
gonna be doing a trailer review of today
is the teaser trailer for the movie
called the purge have you heard of this
movie arzu you know what i have
and i saw it when
um we saw evil dead oh that's right we
saw the trailer when we saw evil dead
yeah right and it just
yeah i'm gonna see the movie you're
gonna see it i thought you don't like
horror films i don't but that one speaks
to me i want to talk about what the evil
dead this person's a glorious studio
picture of the year you know what it's
like in like many years that i didn't
have anything to do on a friday night
and i wanted to hang out with my friends
so you were like oh this thing i hate so
i figured it wasn't an action movie that
would give me like a million levels of
anxiety so i gave in and i watched the
evil dead and any horror scene i just
covered my eyes so you didn't watch 90s
so you watched the scene where they got
to the cabin and that was about it no no
no like i just didn't watch the scene
when the [ __ ] is like cutting her
tongue like i don't want to see that
[ __ ] why not that's like the best parts
of the movie because then the
neurotransmitters in my body send
signals to my tongue that make them like
are hurt
as if i'm like experiencing that phantom
she just broke out into like scientific
explanation now of a movie experience
some discourse [ __ ] let's watch the
review
yeah let's watch it let's play back the
footage
that would be so meta just us doing a
review of our own video
yeah we should review our own videos you
can't tell me that the word trailer and
review don't sound like they're the same
word
they don't sound like the same trailer
and interviews like comment below and
let us know if you think trailer and
reviews sound like the same one no
trailer and review are like the same
thing like a trailer is a review of
something and a review is like a trailer
or something so far from the truth
okay no no a trailer is something
designed to advertise a motion picture
to get you to want to go see it and a
review is like after you've seen it
you're telling people what it is okay i
think there's so many contexts of review
well yeah but but there's only a few
when it comes to movies but the dividing
line is that a review has to happen
after you've seen the movie and the
trailer has to happen before because
it's the advertisement that makes you
want yeah a trailer doesn't say this
movie is good or bad they're trying to
say this movie looks awesome so go watch
it a review is someone telling you if a
movie looks good or bad i guess you're
right
what was i thinking because they don't
have to watch movies it's like ar zoo
but the newspapers don't publish
trailers like it doesn't make any sense
first i want to talk about ethan hawk
he's awesome
ethan hawks in it yeah i know nothing
about this this is from the same people
who did movies like paranormal activity
and insidious
and sinister i think i'm not sure if
it's insidious they say it on the
trailer paranormal activities sinister
insidious oh there's dark skies that's
all bloomhouse at least okay yeah i know
so this movie i'm gonna go watch it
because these guys tend to deliver on
horror movies did you say you're scared
to see the trailer i know a little bit
because i just remembered what it was
about and i got really like antsy
because it's like dark outside and i
started getting all these thoughts in my
head yeah it's already sane rated r for
strong disturbing violence and some
language so you know what this movie
will probably deliver i remember seeing
rated r i see like red
like danger like blood like warning
you're not supposed to see this movie
unless you want nightmares where'd you
get that from i don't know do you get
nightmares from all movies that are
rated r yes
just all movies so when you saw django
unchained you were like oh my god i'm a
slave probably had a dream about slavery
in the next three nights
wow wait a minute that's intense so you
got nightmares about like the hangover i
just i had a dream and there were slaves
in it and those those slaves in my dream
came from the movie the
hangover that's an already you didn't
say jenkins
hangover well i'm sure i had a dream
about partying in vegas after i saw that
yeah that wasn't a nightmare unless it
was an awful party i knew what i [ __ ]
meant it was a shitty party it's okay
persia let's do this the trailer for the
purge
so
tonight allows people a release
for all the hatred and violence if they
keep up inside them why don't you guys
kill someone tonight
because we don't feel the need to johnny
just remember all the good the purge
does
we'll be fine just like always no
worries okay
this is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the
annual purge at the siren all emergency
services will be suspended for 12 hours
your government thanks you for your
participation
help me
someone please help me
i just need to get someone safe
why did you let him in our home we have
no idea who's after him
our target for this year's purge is
hiding in your home
you have one hour to find it and give
them to us
or we'll kill all of
they you get in here right they can't
get into our home
we're gonna make it through tonight and
everything is gonna be okay
nothing is ever going to be okay again
i have chills
i want to watch that movie there's you
know what was really creepy about that
when the when the sun is like why don't
you kill just try it you know what i
mean there's nothing creepier than
seeing us
is that a boy or a girl i can't tell
there's a boy yeah that boy who looks
like a girl
is uh
talking to their parents about you know
what they what happens once a year and
that's that's just creepy right there
and then the trailer just escalates it
looks like it's gonna be a violent
disturbing and very scary [ __ ] movie
this is a sick movie
and i i take it she means sick by
actually the what it means sick no no no
no not cool
disturbing
like
[ __ ] show
for 12 hours
and it makes me wonder
why they make films like this because
dumbasses like in the world will see
[ __ ] like this and try to imitate it in
person that's how you kill people yeah
but well not but you would have to
initiate like a global policy to make
this happen like it's a government yeah
it's a government safety thing yeah no
that's true but like at the same time
like you can perform that action just
amongst your friends or something stupid
you're right yeah just murder your
friends once a night
i think jackass is more it was more
dangerous than that maybe i just think
the worst of situations because it's
clearly a fictitious world and
you know it's it's
never that's never going to happen we
would never do that so it's plain
pretend of what if we were allowed this
opportunity and i love that idea of
exploring that really dark side of what
if we're allowed to commit crime once a
year because they're saying 364 days out
of the year there's no crime except for
one particular day where they're allowed
to get it out of their system because
there are serial killers there are
people who are bad who have these urges
and i'm not i'm not saying they should
condone that but we're not going to stop
all of them the goal is to stop as many
as possible so it's an interesting
concept to me to explore that oh i mean
yeah i mean this is the first time i've
seen that trailer so that i think it's a
definitely cool concept i'm
i'm a little worried
i don't know i love like sinister and
stuff like that i do love cinderella i
think it's a really cool concept i'm
just i'm i'm i'm like i just really hope
they know how to bring it together you
know because it is a
a concept such as this so so high
concept is easy to lose your footing on
so if they can bring it together i think
that'll be awesome what i think is cool
about it is how these guys usually do
like supernatural horror and this seems
to be their first real life even though
it's a fictitious plot and it's
something that won't happen at the end
of the day it's not a supernatural movie
so i love the idea of how they're
actually going for something that's
really raw and realistic does it bother
you to see like a family because i know
you're very family oriented does it
bother you to see like a family in this
much danger no it more so was scary to
see america so happy like that's why you
said it's a fictitious world yeah it's
just like to see the family you just see
like a scene of the family at dinner and
if you just look at all their facial
expressions they're so they're so like
like happy and just like overwhelmingly
like euphoric
you know what i mean so it's just kind
of like throws me off because
the reality is that families aren't like
that 24 7. yeah and it just makes it out
to seem like that and then to have this
perfect family like be involved in this
like situation you know where they're
shooting they're trying to get rid of
the guy who stinks into their house and
all this stuff it's like a scary feeling
like oh my god that can happen i don't
see this is it's just this is why i want
her on the show because she sends she
says stuff in ways that sound like it's
putting the film down but she's saying
exactly what the filmmakers are
intending you know what i mean yeah and
you know what though with that i don't
mean to put the film down i think i'm
more so like damn that's that's kind of
cool but at the same time that's why
it's sick this all supports why the
movie's just so sick like it's twisted
it's like so sick and that's why we're
gonna watch it because it looks sick and
i mean there's there's definitely some
potential for some really
gnarly psychology there having a family
and kids growing up in a world where you
know it's just an annual thing where all
crime is okay for 12 hours like that's
got to warp your mind so is it 12 hours
or is it a day it's 12 hours or allowed
so it's not the whole day so because
they're saying because they announced it
in the trailers 12 hours it's crazy yeah
like okay go ahead no i'm just saying
like what jerry was bringing up about
the psychology like it can't explore
that it looks like it debates about that
like is this okay or is it not okay
hopefully the movie explores that this
is just a trailer so we really don't
know ryan's consensus i hope the purge
scares the living [ __ ] out of me ryan
hopes the purge will scare the living
[ __ ] out of him i like taking shits and
i'm hoping this horror movie will make
me take a [ __ ] is this a straight-up
scary [ __ ]
yeah like a scary [ __ ] like i'm taking a
dump and it's going to be the most
terrifying [ __ ] i've ever seen [ __ ] kind
of like when you're over with it you
like released all the tension you had
flowing through oh that would be a great
feeling jerry's consensus uh uh yeah
i'm down i want to see the purge yeah
jerry wants to see the purge i mean this
is the first i've seen of it it's a cool
concept i love ethan hawk so uh i am i'm
there so arzu are you gonna go watch the
purge or zoo's consensus yes
with a jacket over half my face or she's
gonna watch the purge with the jacket
over half her face
all right people so we're going to move
on to the next film the conjuring the
conjuring conjuring the conjuring what
does that word mean well like you know
if you're conjuring something it's like
you're um
summoning something up okay let's do
that have you heard of this movie now
okay i actually know a little bit of
background on this movie because it's
based off a true story warren files the
warren files what are they what are they
known as the warren
husband and wife or something yeah
they're i believe they're a husband and
wife team of paranormal investing yeah
like demonologists yeah they're expert
people when it comes to like you know
exploring like other demons in the house
or those kinds of people you bring in
and they were real people that existed
wrote a shitload of books and supposedly
this is one of their their most famous
for uh the amityville horror story
because they were the ones who explored
that and i'm excited to see this because
it's from the guy who directed insidious
directed saw oh my gosh is hearing that
there's a silence
sentence and fast and the furious part
seven oh yeah he's doing fast and
furious seven yes
all this is very interesting information
to our zoo can't you tell i don't care
that's okay and i i've seen this trailer
i've seen both trailers this is a teaser
trailer and a theatrical trailer we want
to show you both because they're very
different from one another and i'm
excited to go watch this film and i'm
excited to see her take a [ __ ] all i
know is that patrick wilson's in it oh
yeah patrick wilson star of insidious
usually takes his shirt off in a movie
that's that's why i know some patrick
wilson's naked on stage once he did yeah
for the full monty oh good for him i
wish i was there to see patrick wilson's
penis and vera for migma is in this she
does something vera farmiga she's in the
star she's the star of the new bates
motel
series this prequel to
psycho and she's also in uh the orphan
and the departed so yeah this is gonna
be a good movie i have a feeling this
will be a solid horror film and uh i'm
gonna run i forgot the other girl's name
but she's a famous actress too let's
watch his trailer
three
four
nine
ten
first place
clap
i'm gonna get you now
i can hear you breathing
you took your blindfold off i win mine's
in christina nancy's room
girls it's way past your bedtime
look at that
who's ever down there to lock you in now
all right it's 9 18. we're headed down
into the cellar where the doors just
opened on its own give us a sign that
you want to communicate with us
nothing
what are you guys well we've been called
ghost hunters paranormal researchers but
we prefer to be known simply as ed and
lorraine warren
there's someone here that would like to
talk to you
there's something horrible happening in
my house
it's november 1st 1971 i'm sitting here
with carolyn perrin who with her family
has been experiencing supernatural
occurrences you're picking up anything
in here on
something awful happened here ed
what is it
whatever lorraine sees feels touches it
takes a toll on her a little piece each
time
you have a lot of spirits in here
but there's one that i'm most worried
about because it is so hateful
look what she made me do
we have to get out of here that's not
gonna help this thing has latched itself
to your family
father we never seen nothing like this
i'm coming with you no way i can't lose
you
there's a lady in a dirty nightgown that
i see in my dreams she's standing in
front of my mom's bed
do you want to see him yeah and the
music stops you swim in the mirror
standing behind you
look what she made me do
that movie looks intense yeah okay holy
[ __ ]
yeah that's the reaction i actually
jumped during the trailer of the second
one first off that teaser trailer i love
it because it's like showing you clips
of the movie rather than just being a
long montage of the film that first
trailer i remember seeing that in the
theaters and freaking the [ __ ] out and
now the second trailer really shows you
what this film is about and everything
looks solid from the directing of it the
cinematography the makeup effects the
horror it's gonna be a solid [ __ ] i
have strong confidence this is going to
be a solid movie you know that feeling
when your capillaries and arteries and
veins detach from your heart and your
heart flies out of your body
don't know that feeling almost until
you've got the whole heart flying out
like you know the split five seconds
when you're gonna have a heart attack
and your heart stops beating i haven't
had a heart attack yet so i i don't know
that's what the [ __ ] it feels like it
feels like a heart attack movie that's
what it feels like a heart attack movie
and it just moved me
like to a whole nother level
of nervousness oh yeah and it made me
feel like i was in the damn movie in one
of the bedrooms and i was like hiding
from the little
scary person i love that because that is
exactly why i want to watch it and
exactly why you don't want to watch this
movie not watching this movie honestly
i'm not watching this movie for the sake
of my life that's that makes sense
because i don't want i know that feeling
of not wanting to be haunted after
everybody's done yeah no you know like
i do get i get a little bit like weary
of stuff like this because i grew up
roman catholic and growing up in a world
like that you hear a lot about demons
and supernatural stuff going on so when
i see this it's easy for me to believe
[ __ ] like that can really go on movies
like this
just throw me off because of the mom and
she's taking care of the kids and she's
just so brave it's clear she's like a
single mom in the movie
you know you're bringing up i don't know
i mean she was your own livingston
i don't know ron livingston's up working
you know what i'm yeah judging off the
first trailer that we saw he was never
there it was her that was going oh yeah
that's true and that made that just
reminded me of my mom
and how she's just so protective and
will take that like fearful step of
seeing oh what's wrong with the house
who's in here what's this noise where's
this coming from to protect your
children that's why it's really moving
yeah she seems like a strong woman you
know what's cool about the movie too is
all the performances look very strong as
well ryan's consensus the conjuring
looks like a terrifying experience and
that's why i want to experience it the
conjuring looks like a terrifying
experience and that's why ryan wants to
experience it another movie where i will
take a shake jerry's consensus the
conjuring looks awesome i am definitely
gonna see it jerry thinks the country
looks awesome and he's definitely gonna
see it like i said i mean i'm a big fan
of everybody involved the trailer looks
spooky as hell hell even the poster
looks spooky as hell i am i'm so down
just the the lettering of the conjuring
the way they use the text look that's
creepy creepy but it's also got that
period five yeah it's it's the 70s yeah
yeah they really seem like they brought
the 70s back to life in a way yeah i'm
excited i like 70. are zeus consensus
for the sake of my own life and because
this movie's scary
i refuse to see it for the sake of
arzu's life and because it's scary she
refuses to see it but but you saw evil
dead
that was the like gorgeous
worse this looks a little bit scarier
than evil daddy evil dead is more it
might be scared okay
this is in a house with chicken
it's about a family though you know so
it makes it a lot more perfect
our next movie being
the lords of salem directed by
visionary director rob zombie who
brought us such films as house of a
thousand corpses the devil's rejects
halloween one the remake and halloween
two the sequel to the remake and the
haunted world of el super beast which is
not out yet no it's not it's an animated
movie oh okay i haven't seen it but i
like this guy's films i know some people
i know it's usually 50 50 when it comes
to this guy's movies but i really like
his films a lot i wasn't a big fan of
the halloween movies but i enjoyed house
of a thousand corpses and i love the
devil's rejects i am a huge zombie head
uh i am really excited i mean i haven't
let myself watch the trailer for this
movie yet and i'm gonna have to break
that now uh because i already know i'm
gonna see it i mean you know it's like
you said rob zombie is a he definitely
has his own thing going you know he
makes movies for himself and me
and so i couldn't be more excited
regardless of whether i've seen this
trailer or not he said that this is by
far like cinematically his biggest film
he's made yet from what i've heard it
definitely sounds like good yeah and
jerry like interns that no you internet
worked there i'm a staffer now okay he
works with fangoria and van goria
actually gave this movie some pretty
positive reviews as well uh so the
horror movie community seems to be
loving it from what i see if you're not
a horror movie fan you might not like it
but from the horror movie community
itself they seem to really be enjoying
it do you know who rob zombie is
no musician for regular director next no
at least
no really i'm sure i apologize you've
heard no not dracula ladies and
gentlemen this is the first time i've
seen jerry get upset with a woman
hi
are you the new tenant
they just saw the tenant like 10 minutes
ago standing in the doorway
i hate to break it to you but there is
no person in number five
you
have to understand that there is a war
waging in heaven
is everything all right
now
the curse the lords of salem possessing
the souls of the salem women which the
devil's child would inherit the earth
god does not spare angels when they sin
welcome
that movie looks weird yeah no no no yes
refuse denial it's not refused that's
exactly what she said when watching this
trailer refuse one word it wasn't a full
sentence
there's no way there's no i repeat no
way you could get me to see this film
under any circumstance whatsoever why
it is the epitome of a movie with bad
vibes and being someone that has a
relationship with god i just see that as
something i don't want to see something
i don't want to be involved in and
sucked into for three hours that's
completely speaking bad things into
nature whatever two one
that's that running time comes into
existence like i don't do that i don't
want to be involved with that at first i
didn't even know it was like um a
satan-like movie until i think it's
about it's about which i mean it's it's
about basically satan worship
a witch covenant that's hundreds of
years old uh that was i believe burned
up during the salem witch rounds returns
to modern day salem to take their
revenge it's supposed to be very strange
and surreal and weird and it just
spirals off into madness after a while
and i it's crazy i've seen two trailers
and i'll actually like this trailer more
because it seems to get more of the tone
across that i heard rob zombie was going
for so this because i first heard about
what rob zombie was going for kind of
like a kubrick kind of type of feel do
you know stanley cooper i guess
what is that what is that okay question
two who is stanley cooper 2001 oh my god
the guy in threes company
long or do i tell her the truth what are
you doing today's company i love this
company stanley that was the guy no okay
well stanley is the man who is the
person who did most of the marvel stuff
like the hulk and spiderman
and then there's stanley kubrick who did
movies like the shining have you heard
of that
2001 a space yes i started watching the
first time it's i got bored i don't like
him
okay stanley cooper
that's insulting he is dead yeah and
i'm sorry
it's okay
it's okay i'm sure a lot of people don't
like stanley kubrick's films but anyway
yeah as far as this film goes i'm gonna
be there for sure he actually said he
didn't approach this like a horror movie
you know at all he didn't want people to
think they were doing a horror movie it
was just like let's approach this like
as an actual drama and take it there and
he said at least for now it's probably
his last horror movie ryan's consensus
the lords of salem looks [ __ ] creepy
the lords of salem looks [ __ ] creepy
that's a fact jerry's consensus i'm
definitely seeing this movie jerry's
definitely seeing this movie yeah i know
i love rob zombie um i'm really excited
for something weird again so sign me up
i'm there are zeus consensus
no
refuse
not happening
never no refuse not happening never
well guys that's been our trailer-thon
for today yup tune in next week where i
don't remember what we're gonna be doing
look at your hand while you're doing it
okay ready oh
what are we doing waving like princess
diaries i have seen movies yeah yes i
have seen movies
the princess diaries yeah that is movies
there were two of them
well anyway yeah thanks for hanging out
with us we'll talk to you guys later
you